[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette de 4 100 99e
édition d' interdit d'interdire il y à
une crise entre la france et l'algérie
emmanuel macron a parlé d'un système
politico militaires algériens fatigué le
gouvernement algérien a dénoncé des
propos irresponsables et une ingérence
inadmissible dans les affaires dans ses
affaires intérieures il a aussitôt
rappelé son ambassadeur et interdit le
survol de son espace aérien aux avions
militaires français de l'opération
barque anomalies ce qui devrait encore
rapproché la france du maroc qui est lui
aussi en crise avec l'algérie les
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays sont rompues depuis le 24 août mais
la france est en crise aussi avec le
baroque depuis qu'elle a réduit la
quantité de visas délivrés aux marocains
aux algériens ou tunisiens aussi on va
voir pourquoi et qu'on a appris que le
maroc espionner manuel macron grâce au
logiciel pegasus alors pourquoi toutes
ces crises entre la france ben jerry et
le maroc on en débat avec adlène meddi
vous êtes chercheur en géopolitique
spécialiste du monde arabe vous êtes né
en algérie où vous avez vécu jusqu'en
2005 vous écrivez régulièrement sur le
site middle east high et vous dirigez
haras prisme c'est un site fondé par de
jeunes chercheurs passionnés par les
relations internationales la
géopolitique et le monde arabe alors
vous êtes le premier à qui je pose la
question qu'est ce qui ne va pas d'après
vous entre la france l'algérie et le
maroc alors vous savez il ya cette
fameuse formule de clouds vide qu'on
aime bien répéter à la la la guerre et
la continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens que foucault avait
d'ailleurs renversé dans le cas de la
france et des pays maghrébins vous venez
de citer on est tenté de dire que la
politique étrangère est un peu la
poursuite de la politique intérieure par
d'autres moyens les déclarations des
manuels maquereau ou certaines
déclarations des dirigeants algériens ou
plus généralement les tensions autour de
discours autour de déclarations c'est
souvent
une politique intérieure déguisé en
politique étrangère et ça c'est pour
amuser la galerie au fond ce cas pour
l'occuper c'est souvent pourra pour
amuser une galerie intérieure en tout
cas ce n'est pas censé être la
définition de la diplomatie et de la
politique étrangère eric dénécé vous
êtes directeur du centre français de
recherche sur le renseignement
vous êtes également consultant votre
dernier livre vient de sortir aux
éditions mareuil la nouvelle guerre
secrète que vous avez co écrit avec
alain pierre la clotte alors même
question qu'est ce qui ne va pas entre
le maroc l'algérie et la france d'après
vos bas on se trouve dans un jeu à trois
qui est assez comique en ce moment il ya
effectivement comme l'a dit
l'intervenant précédent des questions
politiques intérieures mais aussi des
sujets plus graves notamment reliées à
la politique internationale si elle est
il y à du maroc que d'un côté avec les
américains et les qu'israël qui sont
déviées anciens la question sahraouie
qui est aussi un sujet de discorde très
importante entre entre l'algérie et le
maroc et puis bien sûr les
revendications constante même si elles
sont en partie pour des questions
politiques intérieures de l'algérie à
l'égard de la france tout ça fait un jeu
croisé assez complexe je pense que nous
allons un petit peu éclaircir h et
d'achat si vous êtes marocain docteur en
sciences économiques consultant
géopolitique chroniqueur sur luxe radio
qui est basée à casablanca même question
qu'est-ce qui va pas entre l'algérie la
france et le maroc
eh bien il ya un chevauchement de
différents facteurs dans le premier
étant le logique très look toral en
france qui font que des thématiques
interne est d'ailleurs imposé notamment
par une certaine droite font confisqués
par l'état afin de ne pas les abandonner
à d'autres franges politique et qui
engagent directement des pays comme
gehry ou dans une moindre mesure du
maroc il ya également des problèmes
internes à l'algérie notamment suite aux
attaques et aux différents
bouleversements qu'a connus le pays qui
font que cela effectivement comme ça a
été dit précédemment
cela se traduit par une politique
extérieure qui cherche à devenir le
prolongement ou bien une forme
d'exutoire pour des problématiques
internes et du côté du maroc c'est très
simple fait que le maroc a entamé depuis
quelques années une tente de
désenclavement diplomatique qui a
commencé à partir de 2015 avec les 2016
avec les visites royales à moscou à
pékin la signature de partenariats
stratégiques
et puis le grand basculement a eu lieu
de manière publique de manière claire en
décembre 2001 avec la reconnaissance
américaine de la souveraineté marocaine
sur le sahara ce qui fait que le maroc a
opéré ce basculement stratégique qui lui
offre un ancrage atlantique est donc une
profondeur stratégique qui dérange
beaucoup de partenaires dont pack
uniquement la france et l'algérie mais
également en espagne l'allemagne un
certain nombre d'autres partenaires et
d'autres pays dits amis qui se
retrouvent totalement déroger par le
fait que le maroc affermi renforce sa
souveraineté par ce basculement
géostratégique sans pour autant rompre
son ancrage avec les partenaires
européens alors commençons par par la
crise entre la france et l'algérie
puisque on l'a appris aujourd'hui des
avions militaires français ne peuvent
plus survolé l'algérie notamment nous
avions militaires qui se rendent au ben
ali et qui reviennent du mali pour
l'opération barkan comment vous
expliquez cette cette crise là les
déclarations de des bagnoles macro que
j'ai cités tout à l'heure qui parle d'un
d'un système
politico militaires algériens fatigué
mais c'est la seule raison je pense que
c'est la principale raison puisque c'est
alors pourquoi l'at il dit parce que
elle elle c'est vrai que l'algérie est
une est un pays où les bulles harb et au
pouvoir mais sa date bien longtemps des
biens je dois avouer que je n'ai pas
très bien compris pourquoi il l'a dit
ni le contexte dans lequel il a dit
sinon j'ai peut-être n'at-il pas tout à
fait penser aux conséquences de ses
déclarations puisque il me semble que
c'était un cercle relativement fermé il
discutait avec de jeunes
personnes concernées par par le passé
colonial de la france et la question
algérienne en particulier de jeu je
pense que c'est une imprudence ensuite
s'agissant de la réponse algérienne
c'est à dire la fermeture de l'espace
aérien qui est devenue ces derniers
temps un outil finalement privilégié de
de représailles de 2,2 du pouvoir
algérien à ça reste quand même
relativement symbolique alors symbolique
parce que ça ne remet pas vraiment en
question les opérations militaires en
cours 1 de ce que j'ai compris les
déclarations de des représentants d'état
major français
l'opération barkan est censé prendre fin
au premier trimestre de l'année 2022
donc dans quelques mois
donc je pense que c'est une sorte de
petite sanction
relativement symbolique janvier d'heure
eric dénécé pourquoi cette crise
aujourd'hui d'après vous on peut d'abord
parce que nous avons en algérie un
pouvoir qui est très très instable et
très très fragile c'est une réaction
symbolique mais c'est quand même une
forme de sur-réaction ça montre le la
manière dont le pouvoir algérien à
doivent d'aller des produits et des
gages sont à son d'opinion à ces médias
je pense qu'il faut rappeler quelque
chose qui est quand même très important
à chaque fois qu'il ya une crise de
cette nature entre la france et
l'algérie c'est qu'il ya près de 800
ministres ou anciens ministres ou
députés algériens qui ont la double
nationalité française qui dispose de
bien en france et qui au cas où les
islamistes reviendrait chercher chez eux
voilà comme dans les années noires que
quand ils paieraient d'absolument
terrible s'empresseraient devenir celle
dont je pense que il faut garder ça à
l'esprit il ya beaucoup d'agitation mais
en dernier recours lancet pts tradition
qu'il y a de critiquer la france pour
des raisons de politique intérieure pour
des raisons passé colonial pour l
exemple politique étrangère c'est malgré
tout la france le premier lieu de
destination des vibrations de la
jeunesse ma gueule l'algérienne et c'est
aussi en cas de problème l'endroit où
bien sûr tous ces caciques algérien
viendrait se réfugie donc il faut bien
sûr
je dirais pondéré un petit peu cette
réaction quelque peu excessive et ne pas
perdre de vue que finalement les liens
avec la france demeurait 3km macron fait
beaucoup de choses pour les pour les
rétablir et qu'on est là sur une petite
période d'énervement en raison du jeu à
3 qu'on écrivait tout à l'heure mais en
même temps comment vous expliquer à la
fois cette proximité avec la france que
vous venez de décrire et cette
propagande anti française qui revient
régulièrement
au sein du gouvernement et des
dirigeants algériens
oui moi je fais une différence terrible
entre le entre le gouvernement et les
élites algériennes est là et la
population elle-même et les élites qui
ne sont qu ils ne sont pas au pouvoir
dans le point de vue est quand même
quelque peu différent c'est un véritable
jeu de politique intérieure comme le
disais tout à l'heure le premier
intervenant c'est quelque chose ne va
pas en algérie effectivement il est
pratique de taper sur la france et qui
je crois aussi qu'il faut rappeler que
nos amis algériens regardent tout autant
les médias français que les médias
algériens et donc dès que nous avons des
débats intérieurs en france où des
critiques ont l'algérie où nous en sang
sont l'algérie au maroc peu importe ça à
retentissement beaucoup plus grands
comptes l'imaginent de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée est donc parfois des
propos qui sont tenus chez nous et qui
n'étaient destinés qu'à débats
intérieurs rebondissent en algérie et
ont parfois des effets et le secondaire
que l'on auquel on ne s'attend pas
toujours rapide achats chez
bayard différents éléments fait que
premièrement on peut l'inscrire dans une
logique là encore pré électoral avec une
droitisation du discours de mc ren qui
cherche à s'aligner sur les thématiques
d'eric zemmour pour ne pas citer où
effectivement une france qui refuse de
s'auto flageller en permanence d'être
dans le discours victimaire la haine de
soi et que c'est une manière d'affirmer
qu'en tant que chef de l'état y des
solides capables de la firme et
politiquement contrairement à d'autres
qui nous font que des commentaires sur
différents médias premiers éléments le
deuxième élément qui me permet peut-être
d'affirmer que ça va au delà d'une
logique électorale ce que dire quand
même il ya quelques semaines il ya eu de
la démarche de macron de demander pardon
aux harkis avec une logique de noix
réparatrice qui va être mise en place
probablement donc peut-être qu'un an que
donne est en train d'assister un petit
basculement une nouvelle tendance et du
point de vue de la diplomatie française
où le jeu se clarifie parce que pendant
très longtemps du côté marocain d'une
autre on a reproché relativement à la
france une forme de neutralité active
dans le dossier maroco algérien alors
que je dis neutralité active parce que
c'est une neutralité qui n'est pas à la
hauteur du rôle de la france dans la
région qui est quand même un partenaire
économique et à tous les niveaux
stratégique autant du maroc de l'algérie
et donc elle ne peut pas se permettre un
retrait de ce genre et pourquoi active
parce que cette neutralité de nature à
aggraver les tensions avant que la
france pourrait se proposait notamment
en tant que médiatrice ont en tout cas
de créer des canaux de dialogue entre le
maroc et l'algérie sachant comme vous
l'aviez rappelé au début que l'algérie a
rempli de manière unilatérale les
relations diplomatiques
avec le maroc quatre jours après la main
tendue par le roi du maroc à l'algérie
lors du discours à l'occasion de la fête
du trône donc on est dans une logique où
on a effectivement un pays avec de fins
toutes ses limites ses défauts et ses
qualités qu'elle maroc mais qui est
stable politiquement qui est un
partenaire fiable au niveau sécuritaire
qui collaborent avec les autorités
françaises et d'autres autorités
européennes et de l'autre côté on a un
pays qui qui qui dort sur une forme de
rente mémorielle autour d'une mémoire
qu'il a quelque part co construit avec
la france puisque je rappelle que dans
l'hymne national algérien la france est
cité au moins deux fois donc on est donc
il est très compliqué de parler
d'ingérence de la france dans le cas de
l'algérie au même moment même où
l'algérie a bâti sa mémoire autour de la
france donc on est dans une logique très
différente content barre de l'algérie de
la france d'un côté quand on parle du
maroc et de la france de l'autre côté a
fortiori entre le maroc et l'algérie ces
différents dossiers il ya des
chevauchements il ya des croisements en
réalité c'est au cas par cas donc c'est
une problématique pour l'instant
principalement faute franco-algérienne
le maroc à d'autres problématiques avec
la france ait eu déjà des froid
diplomatique le dernier en 2014 entre le
maroc et la france et une logique
récurrentes à chaque fois que la gauche
est au pouvoir en france ça crée des
tensions avec le maroc ce qui n'est pas
le cas actuellement mais je pense qu'il
ya une tendance de fond du point de vue
de la diplomatie française dans un
schéma de clarification et d'arbitrage
entre le maroc et l'algérie du point de
vue de paris depuis 60 ans maintenant
que l'algérie est indépendante et que le
fln et l'armée sont au pouvoir
on a l'impression alors à passer les dix
ans qui ont suivi la dépendance on a
l'impression qu'en permanence on
soupçonne la france de soutenir le
activement le pouvoir algérien et le
pouvoir algérien en même temps ne cesse
de reprocher à la france ses tentatives
d'ingérences mais qu'en est il
exactement
est-ce qu'il ya véritablement la gérance
est ce qui a véritablement collusion
ou est ce qu'il y a véritablement
comme aujourd'hui on veut nous le dira
une une mise à distance de l'un et de
l'autre je pense que vous avez bien
résumé la situation en disant qu' il y a
d'un côté un véritable soutien
apporté par paris au pouvoir algérien et
on l'a remarqué pendant l'heure et halak
c'est à dire le soulèvement populaire
puisque même les dernières propositions
de 2,2 prolongement du mandat d'un
président de ta filipacchi était
moribond était salué par la france qui
était assez assez assez incongru donc il
ya bien soutien apporté au pouvoir
algérien d'ailleurs le président macron
l'a répété récemment en saluant le sur
le mot log algérien donc il ya bien un
soutien mais en face côté algérien je
pense que la question française est
commode en termes de diversion et en
terme de deux tentatives
de création d'une pseudo cohésion autour
de cette question mémorielle
des deux thématiques comme celle de la
main étrangère souvent appréciée par le
pouvoir algérien donc tout cela tout
cela n'est pas nouveau ce qui est
ironique par contre c'est que ça n'a pas
marché pendant l'heure et c'est à dire
que pendant vous savez le soulèvement a
commencé en février 2019 pendant les
manifestations hip hop contre l'arrêt le
énième réélection de bouteflika qui de
toute façon n'était plus de 80 en état
de gouverner quoi que ce soit contre le
pouvoir en général quand le pouvoir
algérien en général et son caractère
militaire puisque les premiers slogans
belle dès le début les premiers slogans
c'était un état civil et pas militaire
ce qui est des slogans encore répété
aujourd'hui
donc mais ça n'a pas marché le le le le
la france comme comme
épouvantail susceptible de ralentir ce
soulèvement populaire ça n'a pas marché
et ça n'a pas marché et du coup on se
demande pourquoi le président français a
cru devoir à deux reprises au moins
évoqué la question mémorielle
d'abord en commandant un rapport à
l'historien benjamin stora alors que la
question de se poser par en algérie ni
en france que je sache en tout cas pas
aujourd'hui et lens-caen répétons
justement on évoquant dans un cadre
privé ou ou public cette question
mémorielle c'est à dire qu'au près comme
la comme l'a indiqué tout à l'heure eric
denécé c'est à dire que ça ne marche pas
auprès de la population algérienne et au
prix d'une partie des élites algériennes
ça ne marche pas parce que les
préoccupations sont ailleurs il ya un
problème face à un pouvoir en place le
fait de répéter systématiquement
la ritournelle de la main étrangère à ça
fonctionne beaucoup moins qu'il ya
quelques décennies eric denécé
votre avis le la france soutient le
pouvoir algérien depuis au moins 50 ans
maintenant ou au contraire
était le plus proche à présent des
d'une certaine élite algérienne et de
cette jeunesse qui manifeste kamal
infesté régulièrement contre ce pouvoir
non nous soutenons surtout le régime
algérien depuis longtemps alors avec des
modalités différentes selon les périodes
et notamment de manière assez discrète
pendant les années noires avec deux
objectifs c'était d'éviter effectivement
la montée de cet islamisme en algérie ce
qui n'a pas pu être malheureusement
éviter les surtout qu'elle déborde sur
notre territoire et puis les questions
d'immigration mais moi je voudrais
revient l'anecdote très amusante je me
trouvais pour les 50 ans d'indépendance
de l'algérie à alger et je discutais
avec rza bras qui était le conseiller
antiterroriste de bouteflika à l'époque
et je lui demandais pourquoi est-ce que
l'indépendance n'était pas aussi fêté
j'étais surpris de ne pas voir plus de
manifestations et il m'a répondu tu sais
on en a pas fini avec notre être alors
je dis mais de petits tubes parler ce
que ce sens est requis
l'inondent au traître au sein du fln tu
sais très bien quand on critique la
france c'est d'avoir pour des questions
de politique intérieure donc on est
vraiment dans ce jeu là il ya par contre
parfois d un certain nombre de choses
plus profondes et je crois que
l'ambivalence où on va dire le les coûts
distance qui est aujourd'hui celle de la
france entre le maroc et l'algérie elle
s'explique assez bien c'est que nous
avons bien sûr d intérêt à garder de
bonnes relations avec nos amis algériens
parce que l'histoire et malgré ces ses
aspects les plus les plus tristes et les
plus cruels nous a quand même réuni
pendant longtemps et d'un autre côté les
relations avec le maroc ne sont pas
toujours aussi bonne que cela jeu il
faut quand même rappeler qu'au maroc
très rarement acheter des matériels
militaires français donc c'est un pays
qui se fournit essentiellement auprès
des américains sa set ça déplaît quand
même en france il ya bien sûr les
questions du trafic de drogue également
qui sont pour pour les douanes et les
stups en france une vraie préoccupation
et puis je dirais il ya aussi un élément
qui est important d'avoir à l'esprit
c'est que via des poursuites judiciaires
en france à plusieurs reprises notamment
contre les responsables des services
marocains et tout ça ça devient
également pourrir les relations avec les
crabes à et donc on est un petit peu sur
un sur un équilibre instable tour à tour
tel ou tel pays est plutôt en vogue à
paris et un autre moment il le sera un
petit peu moins acide hh est d'après
vous la france est elle le meilleur
soutien de tous les pouvoirs
en afrique du nord
quelques noms bat déjà je ne mettrai pas
je ne mettrai pas tous les pays de la
rive nord dans un même panier chaque
pays est un cas particulier dans le cas
de l'algérie on a clairement une volonté
d'entretenir une politique extérieure
autonome d'ailleurs je rappelle qu'à ce
titre l'algérie n'a pas d'alliés
ouvertement d'allier et là des
partenaires contrairement à d'autres
pays qui ont opéré un ancrage d'un côté
ou de l'autre mais le problème c'est que
quand on veut mener une politique
extérieure autonome alors qu'on n'a pas
les fondamentaux et les facteurs de
puissance qui vont avec et bien
naturellement ça se traduit par plus
d'autoritarisme en interne parce que
cette politique extérieure indépendante
et autonome se traduit par une
dégradation du niveau de vie par une
confiscation de l'appareil productif de
l'état et qui ne peut être entretenu que
par plus d'autoritarisme en vue d'éviter
que ça déborde en le problème c'est que
l'état algérien est conscient du fait
qu'il est confronté une jeunesse qui est
le produit d'une rupture générationnelle
puisqu'il n'a pas connu les affres de la
guerre civile est donc cet argument de
sénou le chaos ne marche plus avec cette
nouvelle génération de jeunes de jeunes
algériens que peut-être les propos de
macron ne relève pas d'une maladresse je
n'y crois pas du tout mais c'est plutôt
une fuite contrôlée dont la finalité de
s'adresser directement à la jeunesse
algérienne et pas aux autorités
algériennes en leur disant que écouter
quelque part indirectement la sylve
autres pays et se développer s'il
n'arrive pas à émerger malgré le
potentiel dont il dispose ce n'est
aucunement la faute de la france mais
c'est la faute d'un régime qui a
confisqué votre appareil productif votre
appareil politique et que vous devez
vous même faire le boulot donc c'est une
forme d'ingérence franches et ouvertes
opérée par macro donc et c'est de nature
même a invité les algériens à mettre à
mal le régime algérien donc c'est une
ceinture si tu fais ça extrêmement
compliqué donc la réaction d'alger est
une réaction qui est symbolique et le
fait de rappeler l'ambassadeur aux
consultations le fait effectivement de
fermer l'espace aérien des vols
militaires et épices phénoménal vu que
d'opérations barkan étant est en cours
de retrait et qu'on est en train d'y
mettre fin du co2 du côté français mais
on pourra plus faire comme si ça n'a pas
eu lieu vers les propos de macron il ya
un avant il ya un après c'est à dire que
peut-être pour la première fois ma
tranquille n'est certes pas historien et
anthropologue a quand même dit à sa
manière un certain nombre de vérités qui
dérangent et qui permettent de casser
cet alibi permanent mis en avant par
alger pour justifier des problèmes en
interne relatif au développement
économique et à la condition économique
et sociale d'une partie de la population
algérienne qui étaient inondées par une
logique de rente pétrolière qui devient
de plus en plus compliqué à tenir depuis
la crise de 2008 et puis l'effondrement
du prix des hydrocarbures en 2011 2012
et 2013 vous êtes d'accord adlène meddi
au fond ce que dit macron là c'est que
si la situation en algérie est ce
qu'elle est ça n'est pas notre faute
j'ai quelques désaccords avec mon
camarade à casablanca
notamment sur les distinctions qu'il
opère entre les la place de l'algérie du
maroc sur la scène internationale
certes l'algérie n'a pas d'alliés à
proprement parler elle a des partenaires
mais c'est le cas d'un pays comme la
russie vous savez dans la nouvelle
doctrine russe en politique étrangère on
parle plus d'alliances mais on parle de
partenariat je suis pas ce que ça veut
dire grand chose ce qui est certain en
revanche c'est que
l'algérie s'entend très bien avec
l'ensemble des grandes puissances pékin
moscou washington les relations avec
paris sont très bonne plutôt bonne j'ai
envie de dire indépendamment des
discours comment comme on l'a vu pendant
le soulèvement populaire
dans le monde arabe
la preuve au moment de la détention
algéro-marocaine les pays arabes du
golfe les ont pratiquement renvoyer dos
à dos donc l'algérie a des soutiens
aussi dans les pays du golfe l'algérie
le deuxième acheteur d d d armes
émiriennes delà de la de l'industrie
militaire imérienne balbutiante donc je
suis pas sûr que la distinctes que qu'on
puisse parler d'autonomie algérienne au
contraire je pense que le pouvoir
algérien a su se rendre plutôt
incontournable sur la scène
internationale précisément parce qu'il
n'est pas légitime à l'intérieur ensuite
sur les déclarations d' emmanuel macron
certes ce n'est pas un anthropologue ce
n'est pas un chercheur mais je pense que
parfois il un bien s'intéresser aux
débats intellectuels ils oublient
parfois la distinction entre la
recherche les débats intellectuels et la
politique en l'occurrence la politique
étrangère et je pense qu'il l'a il s'est
permis des choses
que sur le plan diplomatique il n'était
pas censé dire parce que je vais pas
utiliser le mot ingérence qui t'a monde
frisé par le pouvoir algérien mais je
dirai tout simplement que les débats sur
la rente mémorielle en algérie ou parce
qu'il va plus loin les débats sur
l'existence ou non d'une nation
algérienne avant 1830 etc sont des
débats algéro algérien et ça on peut pas
le nier c'est à dire que il a le droit
un chercheur des gens qui ont un lien
avec l'algérie des européens d'algérie
des juifs d'algérie ont le droit de
s'exprimer sur ce sujet c'est un sujet
la liberté d'expression devrait le
permettre mais un président de la
république française n'a pas à dire aux
algériens si il était une nation à tel
moment où si à une rente mémorielle de
toutes les manières le débat sur la
route mémorial est un débat qui existe
en algérie et que les les acteurs du lac
n'ont cessé de de reprendre et justement
de les citer ckb l'air de dire rachida
chelsea c'est que si dit ça il s'adresse
aux jeunes algériens il leur dit bah
écoute et fait le ménage parce
qu'effectivement ça fait soixante ans
que ça dure soixante ans c'est très long
la dictature communiste en union
soviétique a duré à peine plus longtemps
c'est à dire que de dire encore que
c'est la faute de la france de la
colonisation etc ça fait 60 ans mais qui
le dit ça se peut à ce que les algériens
quand ils se sont soulevés contre le
pouvoir ont brandi des pancartes la
france ceci ou la france l'a absolument
pas la france était été complètement
inexistants dans les préoccupations
algérienne donc il le dit maintenant
mais pourquoi ne l'at il pas dit dans ce
cas si c'était vraiment sur la tension
au moment de ra que c'est à dire en mars
2019 pourquoi ne l'at il pas dit quand
l'algérie avait un président sans vie
dont je pense que le discours
contre-révolutionnaires au profit de la
sacro-sainte stabilité parce qu'on parle
toujours une stabilité à court terme
c'est un discours qui a triomphé en
europe et en france
on ne soutient pas les soulèvements dans
le monde arabe on a soutenu des rebelles
armés ici ou là en syrie en libye mais
on n'a pas tout on se cale il pouvoir en
place est allée pouvant en place au nom
de la stabilité et et je pense que c'est
encore la position de la france soutenir
le pouvoir en place en algérie
au nom de la stabilité et enfin je
dirais que en termes de coopération avec
la france sur les questions de sécurité
ou de l'immigration
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille est
distingué véritablement l'algérie et le
maroc certes
le camarade à casablanca raison de dire
que on en n'est pas au même point en
terme de régime il ya un problème
aujourd'hui le régime algérien est
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus contestées
certes mais dans la coopération avec la
france en termes de renseignement en
termes de d'immigration on serait dans
le narcissisme la petite différence si
on disait l'un coopèrent plus avec
l'autre en faisant tout on fait une
pause et puis on avance dans le débat et
notamment on va s'intéresser mais
justement à la question des visas
[Musique]
elle serait de retour en france
l'inflation en un an les prix à la
consommation ont augmenté d'1 9% selon
les dernières données de l'insee vous
avez aujourd'hui une inflation qui est
plus due à une désorganisation signolet
des circuits de production et des
circuits de distribution plutôt que une
réelle inflation de la demande
l'inflation ressentie par les ménages ne
correspond pas forcément
à l'inflation
qui est mesuré par l'insee tout ce qui
est pris d'énergie loyer et ses
terrasses qui pèse très lourd dans le
budget des ménages qui sont en bas de
l'échelle sociale du coup se retrouvent
sous-estimé par ces instituts
conjoncture c'est quand même assez clair
pour moi c'est un chiffre qui est archi
politique donc de marketing politique il
pourrait quand même s'ils le voulaient
parce que c'est pas très compliqué avoir
des méthodes qui serait un petit peu
plus réaliste
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc insu réalité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur les relations
compliquées entre la france l'algérie et
le maroc avec trois géopolitologue and
algeria de l'aisne mohammedi un français
c'est eric denécé et un marocain c'est
rachid el chi alors ben ma question est
pour vous et eric denécé et puis ils
réagiront juste après pourquoi d'après
vous la france réduite elle le nombre de
visas accordés à l'algérie au maroc et à
la tunisie
eric qui coûta comme on l'a dit nous
sommes en période pré-électorale et le
risque pour emmanuel macron c'est de se
laisser dépasser sur sa droite et
notamment de permettre des partisans de
zemmour de xavier bertrand de marine le
pen de remporter plus de deux voix et
donc il est tout à fait dans cette
politique il est tout à fait légitime à
ses yeux dessillés durcir un petit peu
son discours alors c'est bien sûr un
calcul électoral classique et pathétique
par certains aspects c'est aussi un
calcul qui correspond à un nom d'une
réalité de terrain qui est qui est
importante dans la mesure où
effectivement le problème aujourd'hui le
problème de l'immigration est un
problème d'intégration dire que nous
avons des exemples merveilleux de deux
jeunes français d'origine maghrébine qui
réussissent dans le pays mais nous avons
aussi des exemples contraires et je
pense que le discours de macron est
aussi une partie de discours réaliste
qu'il n'a pas voulu voir pendant ses
cinq premières années et qui se base sur
cette analyse en prenant conscience
peut-être un peu tard que c'est un
élément important dans la population
française eric denécé ont fait le lien
aussi avec le fait que aussi bien
l'algérie le maroc et la tunisie
refusent de reprendre un certain nombre
de leurs ressortissants quand ils
sortent de prison et que ce serait le
lien avec avec sa qui induirait la
réduction du nombre de visas c'est un
chantage oui bon oui c'est ça c'est une
autre explication évidemment siècle
autant dans le cas de mohamed merah
quand le quand ce terroriste pour avoir
été battue a été demandée et son père a
demandé à être enterré ce que son fils
soit enterré en algérie que les
algériens juste titre on dit écoutez ce
garçon est français on n'en veut pas
chez nous ça c'était quelque chose
qu'ils étaient légitimes autant
effectivement dans le cadre des
personnes en situation irrégulière que
le gouvernement français souhaite
expulser que les gouvernements marocain
ou algérien refuse de reprendre on est
là dans une situation un petit peu
bloquée et il était assez
naturel que les français c'est de faire
monter la pression et ce qui est
d'ailleurs l'explication des tensions
actuelles rachid h et si
oui alors bon c'est évoquer pertinemment
la logique électorale et en plus c'est
pas fondée par les chiffres parce que
quand on voit l'évolution du nombre de
visas octroyés par la france au maroc
bat déjà il ya un effondrement bien
avant les déclarations du porte parole
du gouvernement en français ont raison
de la pandémie due qu'aux vite puisqu'on
est déjà passé de quelques centaines de
milliers de visas octroyés annuellement
à quelques milliers voire quelques
dizaines de milliers d'ong réduire de
moitié ce qui était déjà réduit par dix
en raison de la pandémie me paraît
davantage ressembler un coup d'épée dans
l'eau qu'à une vraie politique de
contrôle migratoire mais ça permet de
développer une rhétorique au
effectivement présentes macro comme
l'homme d'état le chef d'état capable de
mettre un terme à cet afflux migratoire
et de mettre la pression sur ce qui est
présenté de manière très condescendant
par le porte parole du gouvernement
comme étant un pré carré puisqu'il a
parlé de pressions de menaces et que
maintenant ils exécutent un certain
nombre de menaces donc on ne parle pas
des partenaires stratégiques comme on
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure de cette
manière là mais on parle là des pays que
l'on veut garder dans une logique de pré
carré ce qui ne correspond pas au réel
là on connaît très bien comment fait on
fait évoluer la diplomatie entre nos
différents pays on sait très bien que le
maroc collabore par rapport à la lutte
contre le terrorisme et qu'il a déjà
fourni énormément d'informations qui ont
permis de neutraliser des terroristes
sur le territoire français mais que le
problème c'est que effectivement il ya
des micros ou des migrants clandestins
qui doivent être rapatriés chez veut or
le problème c'est que le maroc ne peut
pas automatiquement octroyé à laisser
passer avant de vérifier leur identité
car il y en a beaucoup qui ont brûlé
leurs documents d'identité d'ailleurs en
drague à dire ceux qui brûlent leurs
documents une fois qu'ils atteignent
l'autre rive afin de ne pas pouvoir être
renvoyé donc il ya une enquête qui doit
être mené il ya ministère de l'intérieur
marocain qui doit vérifier les
empreintes digitales donc ce n'est pas
systématique
et d'ailleurs le ministre affaires
étrangères du maroc a rappelé que le
maroc a octroyé plusieurs centaines de
laisser passer à des marocains qui
devaient être rapatriés après avoir
vérifié leur identité donc je ne vois
pas quel intérêt aurait le maroc
d'interdire à des marocains de revenir
au maroc d'autant plus que s'il s'agit
d'éventuels terroristes ou de gens
dangereux pas les dossiers par rapport à
ces personnes existent de part et
d'autre du maroc et de la france donc on
est également dans une rhétorique
effectivement électorale qui n'est
fondée ni sur leurs ailes ni sur les
chiffres et conquérante et en efficacité
ni sur les arguments qualitatifs comme
les laissez passer ou autre chose mis en
avant et il donne et c'est pourquoi le
maroc effectivement où l'algérie ou la
tunisie refuserait de reprendre leurs
ressortissants
très sincèrement c'est la question que
je me pose également il ya en dehors des
arguments qui vient d'être donnée qui
est tout à fait fondée de l'individu qui
pourrait ne pas être marocains tunisiens
ou algériens et qui alors quitte à ne
veulent pas quitter le territoire
français qui serait un danger ou une
menace pour les trois états du sud de la
méditerranée il ya peut-être une
explication c'est qu'on sait très bien
que une partie alors elle elle est
variable selon les états les plus
importantes en afrique noire mais une
partie de ces états vivent ta profite
plus également d'une rente qui est celle
que large de l'argent envoyé dans les
pays d'origine par tous les travailleurs
il me alan immigrés légaux ou non des go
qui sont repris dans le pays donc ça
peut être une autre une autre
explication mais cette explication de
barils plus valable pour les pays
d'afrique noire que pour les pays
d'afrique du nord et elle me dit oui je
suis complètement d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit
je pense qu'il y à la question raider
formelle celle des fameux laisser passer
consulaire que les les algériens et les
marocains et les tunisiens des livres de
façon assez parcimonieuse pour les
raisons qui ont été rappelés
expliquer ce que sont les laissez passer
consulaires c'est une fois qu'il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle en france une oblique
obligation de quitter le territoire
français
il faut encore faut-il que l'état
concernés délivrent aussi un laissez
passer consulaires précisément comme l'a
dit monsieur hachey parce que souvent
c'est ses ressortissants non plus leurs
papiers d'identité donc il faut vérifier
leur identité et on parle en général de
personnes qui sont là depuis quelques
années depuis longtemps donc je ne suis
pas certain qu'il y ait un lien avec la
question des visas des cons bon on a
l'impression comme ça de loin que les
gens qui viendront en france depuis le
maroc où depuis l'algérie avec un visa
de touriste vienne deviennent
automatiquement des clandestins n'ont la
plupart des gens viennent faire du
tourisme ou rendre visite à leur famille
puis rentrer mais la question de la de
l'immigration clandestine est autrement
plus tragique puisque on parle de gens
suffisamment désespérée pour prendre des
embarcations de
2,2 de fortune et qui risque de leur
faire donc il ya cette question formelle
des laissez passer il ya cette question
électorale qui a été rappelée puisque le
contexte n'est pas anodin puisque c'est
une question qui se pose depuis
plusieurs années pourquoi le dire
maintenant à un moment donné où le
nombre de visas a chuté de 80% un de 80%
entre
2020 entre 2019 et 2020 le chiffre est
devenu dérisoire aujourd'hui donc
pourquoi en parler aujourd'hui si ce
n'est pour des raisons
électorales il y a si je puis me
permettre plus généralement cette
permanence de la culture ou de la
logique des sanctions dans la gestion
des questions étranger en l'occurrence
il s'agit d'une sanction d'une punition
collective qu'on inflige à toute cette
population
comme si ça allait d'un seul coup
pousser les autorités à délivrer plus de
laisser passer à des gens qui n'ont
aucune intention de rentrer chez eux et
qu'ils sont même parfois déterminé à
revenir s'il le fallait alors pourquoi
cette crise entre le maroc et l'algérie
je leur ai donc un peu depuis août les
relations diplomatiques sont totalement
rompu entre les deux pays ça n'est pas
la première fois mais mais là c'est
particulier rachida cherchiez vous
l'expliquez comment vous alors on sait
bien quelles histoires du du sahara
abouti depuis très très longtemps à quoi
d'ailleurs depuis le maroc a répondu en
soutenant les velléités d'indépendance
de la kabylie mais mais mais à part ça
qu'est-ce qu'il ya exactement entre les
deux
sans remonter à il ya plusieurs
décennies pour parler des médias t il ya
différents éléments
mier et a le choix opérés par le maroc
de mettre fin à la stratégie de la
chaise vide à dire en évitant d'intégrer
les structures où le polisario et 13 ans
et donc ça s'est traduit par le retour
du maroc au sein de l'union africaine
est donc d'opérer tout un lot been qui a
permis de basculer de basculer de
provoquer un changement de position d'un
certain nombre de pays africains qui
reconnaissait la légitimité du polisario
et l'indépendance de ce qu'il appelle le
sahara occidental en valeur d'une
position pro marocaines notamment à
travers une logique consulaires
indirects qui permet une reconnaissance
indirecte en attendant que l'onu nous
débloque la situation
et puis le deuxième élément c'est que le
maroc avec sa nouvelle doctrine
diplomatique et adopter un temps un peu
plus offensif
c'est à dire que vous mettez en avant le
droit d'autodétermination des peuples
par rapport à une population qui est
pleinement intégrée au maroc il suffit
de prendre un avion daley laâyoune et
abdallah et vous trouvez des villes vous
trouver une activité des gens des
citoyens qui votent
contrairement à tindouf où c'est plutôt
à nos paysages qui est présent que ce
côté là et que le maroc a adopté une
forme de d'inversion accusatoire en
disant que si vous voulez aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique alors had alors
adoptant la même logique par rapport à
la kabylie qui a un peuple relativement
homogène ethniquement qui en profondeur
historique été victime d'un certain
nombre de violations de droit de la part
de l'état algérien et de négation de
leur identité si vous réclamez une autre
permis nation pour lequel la population
marocaine du sud bat on réclamera la
même chose par rapport à la kabylie or
il est évident que cette inversion
accusatoire a été très mal vu du point
de vue de l'algérie et si j'étais
algérien j'aurais très bien compris
pourquoi mais tu prends de vue marocain
on est davantage sur une position
défensive où on défend une forme de
légitimité de la souveraineté marocaine
sur les territoires du sud plutôt que
dans une volonté de provoquer un
éclatement de l'algérie donc cette
inversion accusatoire qui a été l'un des
moteurs de la rhétorique algérienne de
ces dernières années parce que omar sy
enel il ya eu avant également des
déclarations par rapport à la kabylie et
bien tout simplement fait une invitation
à arrêter avec cet argumentaire algérien
par rapport à la marocanité du sahara
parce qu'il est tout simplement
anachronique et que la diplomatie
mondiale et que le paysage diplomatique
mondiale a changé et qu'on n'est plus
dans cette logique de multilatéralisme
totalement stérile qui bloque en
permanence tous les dossiers qui sont
déposés à l'onu et qu'aujourd'hui on a
vu avec les états unis c'est plutôt le
bilatéralisme qui s'instaurait de pete
rock de manière ouverte et franche et
qui permet de faire avancer les choses
qui permet d'aller de l'avant est pas de
tout simplement de plaquer une vente de
salafisme du droit international sans
prendre en compte les particularités
locales et la réalité des dossiers de
l'ennemi mais dit est ce que le pouvoir
algérien se serviraient au fond du maroc
comme de la france pour
c'est tout à fait vrai mais j'avais
quand même répondre sur ce point très
précis il faut aussi quand même avoir
l'honnêteté de dire que situation en
kabylie ne ressemble pas la situation
serra occidentale d'abord la
volonté d'autonomie en kabylie est très
minoritaire si les gens que je connais
bien le lui il n'y a pas de mouvements
de grands mouvements indépendantistes
kabyle la question kabyle n'est pas une
question portée par les nations unies et
je pense que le discours marocain
c'était une sorte de petite réponse
petite provocation diplomatique
qui a
que l'algérie je pense que le pouvoir
algérien aurait pu laisser passer dans
un autre contexte mais comme on est dans
un contexte où le régime algérien et
délégitimé à l'intérieur ça il faut bien
le rappeler utilisé sera utilisé la
question marocaine comme on utilise la
question française encore une fois
c'était quand même un contexte très
particulier pour reprendre deux sets
pour évoquer cette politique intérieure
ça a été fait à un moment de 210
tragique justement qui touchait les le
nord de l'algérie en particulier la
kabylie et le pouvoir algérien a cru
devoir montrer du doigt deux mouvements
tout à fait marginaux en algérie un
mouvement islamo conservateur et un
mouvement autonomiste kabyle tout à fait
marginaux et d'accuser le maroc d'être
derrière ces mouvements est derrière ces
incendies là on part évidemment d'une
réponse complètement excessive du je
dirais d'une diversion mais je n'irais
pas jusqu'à dire que effectivement la
question du sahara occidental est une
question anodine puisqu'elle est
justement porté aux nations-unies je
n'irai pas jusqu'à dire que la question
kabyle équivaut à cette question puisque
dans les faits ça n'est pas le cas et je
ne nierai pas non plus jusqu'à saluer la
politique étrangère de donald trump qui
a consisté en une sorte de transactions
normalisées avec israël en échange
je reconnais votre souveraineté sur le
sahara occidental ce qui est d'ailleurs
on our international depuis si je puis
me permettre une aberration puisque ça
ne veut pas dire grand-chose de
reconnaître la souveraineté d'un état
sur un territoire donné eric dénécé
oui alors il faut reconnaître que le
maroc est aujourd'hui dans une phase
plutôt positives non seulement la
reconnaissance par les américaines sa
souveraineté sur le le seul l'ex sahara
espagnol est quelque chose d'important
mais on a bien vu au cours de la
dernière décennie et et des décennies
qu'on précédé petit à petit les soutiens
des sahraouis comment dire se réduire
donc
ces sont des choses qui bien sûr sont
des camouflets pour l'algérie
j'ajouterai à ça la diplomatie de plus
en plus active du maroc sur ce qu'il
appelle sa zone l'historique d'influencé
dans la zone sahélo saharienne alors que
les algériens eux-mêmes considère que
les pays qui sont à l'heure sud doivent
relever d'une forme de
commandites d'affluence algérienne
également donc tout ça ne fait que
compliquer les choses il ya un autre
élément que je rappellerai d'abord que
le fonds publics le maroc quand même
soutenu le fln pendant la guerre
d'indépendance contre contre la france
que il ya toujours des problèmes
frontaliers qui demeurent entre
l'algérie le maroc et qui a beaucoup de
familles qui se trouvent des deux côtés
de cette frontière et puis il ya une
question qui ne faut pas sous-estimer
qu'est la question israélienne depuis
les années 50 les et le maroc les
services marocains ont toujours été très
proches des services y sera d'ailleurs
c'est une curieusement une chose qui est
finalement peu connu en france mais la
sphère ben barka est une affaire qui a
été montée par les services israéliens
par les services marocains et par des
barbouzes français et dans lequel le
deuil qu'à l'époque n'avait strictement
rien à voir contrairement à ce que
certains journalistes continuent à
colporter est salée les algériens dont
j'avais oublié les dificultés sur le
comment dire de politiques indiens sont
aussi liées au fait que le maroc est à
juste titre considéré comme le plus pro
occidentale des des pays du maghreb et
que les algériens ont plutôt bien sûr
une petite son geste progressiste
notamment sur la question palestinienne
et tout ça fait que les nombreux points
de désaccord même s'ils ne sont pas
absolument majeur s'accumulent et
entraîne et entraîne ses difficultés
d'autant qu'ils sont compliqués comme le
disait d'ailleurs très justement le
dernier intervenant par des problèmes de
politique intérieure en alger mais alors
justement pourquoi le maroc s'est il
servi du logiciel pegasus pour espionner
emmanuel macron votre avis rachid hanifi
mais déjà si vous vous remettez jamais
brièvement réagir parce qu'estimant
collègue algérien sait que premièrement
effectivement il n'ya pas de parallèle
que l'on peut clairement établir entre
la question d'accabler la question du
sahara marocain pour différentes raisons
qu'on n'a pas le temps d'essayer mais
l'argument qui consiste à dire beaucoup
de gens m'ont dit où je connais des gens
qui m'ont dit c'est un argument
d'autorité totalement factice ya pas de
sondage ait pas eu de référendum
on a un but
on vous entend plus malheureusement
rachid échelle shiv
je vais on va vous recontacter donc on
vient à la question suivante
pourquoi est ce que le maroc s'est servi
du logiciel pegasus pour pour espionner
notamment emmanuel macron eric denécé
écoutez je j'ignore ce que les marocains
voulez savoir
sur les discussions des vins de mâcon si
quand bien même s'ils l'ont fait c'est
sont des choses qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas ne sont pas connus de manière
factuelle et puis vous savez ça fait
sourire parce que quand on connaît le
monde du renseignement et qu'on veut
pratiquer des écoutes sur un certain
nombre de cibles bien on étudie d'abord
la manière dont l'acide communique dire
qu'on va étudier coûte combien de
téléphones portables ou fixes il dispose
mais ce qu'ils utilisent le téléphone de
sa femme de ses enfants et ce qu'ils
utilisent internet chez l'uimm dans un
cybercafé et c'est une fois qu'on a
identifié tous les moyens de
communication qui peut l'utiliser qu'on
va décider de les écouter si on écoute
qu'un seul téléphone d'une seule
personne à un moment donné on prend le
risque de d'entendre que deux ou trois
pourcent de ces conversations et donc
c'est pour ça que les coudes de pegasus
à moi qu'elles ne soient
particulièrement ciblés pour une raison
précise sur un appareil ou de très
précisément identifiés je n'en vois pas
beaucoup l'intérêt
au delà de lego journalistique a été
donnée autour de cette affaire alors
retour de rachida shashi je vous râlez
parole rachid voilà donc une idée qui a
pas de référendum qui permet
d'identifier le nombre de personnes et
donc je connais des gens ça ne veut
strictement rien dire alors deuxième
élément mon collègue a parlé d'
aberration qualifiant de la politique
étrangère de trump bas et il est employé
en invoquant le droit international
comme étant la référence est il utile de
rappeler que dans les relations
internationales ya ce qu'on appelle les
règles écrit tv règlement écrite et que
les règles non écrites correspondent à
une crypto hiérarchie à une hiérarchie
qui n'est présente dans aucun traité de
l'onu ni convention devenu mais qui
structurent réellement le monde et qu'un
pays qui adopte le réalisme dans sa
démarche idiomatiques ne peut pas
ignorer cette vraie hiérarchie et donc
le droit international en tant que
référentiel universel on ne revient que
c'est en train de voler en éclats déjà
depuis l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique avec le moment unipolaire et
puis aujourd'hui avec l'émergence de
puissances qui ont leur propre vision du
droit international non parentes être
close par rapport aux logiciels pegasus
alors j'ai l'impression que vous
affirmez que c'est une évidence et une
réalité premièrement ça n'a pas été
démontrée je le rappelle il s'agit d'un
collectif de journalistes
si on remonte le financement de ces
collectifs on trouve des fondations bien
connus comme d'open society comme la
sunlight foundation qui est créée par le
même fondateur que l'open society c'est
à dire jours chauds roche qui d'ailleurs
se qualifier de chef d'état sans état et
donc on n'est pas dans une logique de
neutralité journalistique nous on est
dans une logique de projet idéologique
de sociétés ouvertes qu'elles de telles
que théorisée par porter et dont la
finalité est effectivement et de piocher
dans les hits et en éléments fournis par
des lanceurs d'alert ce qui permet de
mettre à mal la souveraineté d'un
certain nombre d'états qui seraient pas
suffisamment ouvert aux capitaux
étrangers pas suffisamment intégré à la
doxa dominante libéral postmoderne et
c'est donc en est loin de pouvoir
affirmer que le de jcb gadget est
effectivement utilisé par le maroc et je
rappelle que l'état marocain a porté
plainte quant au journal l'humanité mais
également d'autres journaux par rapport
à cette affaire là parce que ça relève
tout simplement de l'asie la nation je
ne dis pas que ça n'a pas eu lieu je ne
dis pas que le maroc n'utilisent pas ou
qu'ils utilisent je dis que ce n'est pas
démontrée et que peut-être qu'il serait
plus prudent de parler au conditionnel
davantage que d'affirmer que le maroc a
espionné tel ou tel individu alors que
je rappelle que s'il ya un pays qui
espionnait tous les chefs d'état
d'europe occidentale c'est bien des
états unis ce qui avait été révélé par
snowdon et là par contre on n'a pas eu
la même réaction que par rapport au
maroc là où par contre c'est pas fondé
du tout on a eu deux petites indignation
à l'époque donnons des d'autres chefs
d'état là où c'était pourtant prouvé est
avérée alors effectivement j'aurais dû
mettre que conditionnel
alors je rajoute pas question avec le
conditionnel si le maroc a espionné
emmanuel macron grâce au logiciel
pegasus qu'elle rit coupe quelle raison
y voyez-vous je suis je je pourrais
rejoindre mon camarade même si je suis
navré si je ne fais l'impression utilisé
un argument d'autorité je voulais
simplement dire qu'un dossier était
géré sous l'égide des nations unies et
que l'autre ne l'était pas du tout et ça
n'était pas un dossier international
lors sud / pegasus je pense
effectivement que ce que ce que ça a été
hâtivement présenté comme un dossier
marocain pegasus c'est d'abord un
logiciel l'israélien qu'un certain
nombre des tentes utiliser un peu
partout dans le monde dans le monde
arable les principaux pays à l'avoir
utilisé si je ne m'abuse se sont
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis
le maroc l'a vraisemblablement utilisé
en europe la hongrie lors et
pardon l'aurait vraisemblablement
utilisé la hongrie lors est aussi
vraisemblablement utilisé je ne sais pas
pourquoi on fait ça mais ce que je peux
vous dire et c'est que les pays ali même
les mêmes les alliés entre s'espionnent
les américains ont bien espionné leurs
alliés européens et il ya quelques
années donc je ne pense pas que ce soit
vraiment une rupture d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas eu de réactions
dures ou agressive ou même ferme de la
part de paris après je les échange avec
le
maroc se sont poursuivies donc je ne
pense pas que que la sphère pegasus soit
véritablement une rupture ni une affaire
strictement marocaine comme on a eu
tendance à ne pas le présenter voilà
alors finissons-en avec pegasus et et
l'avenir alors il nous reste quatre
minutes entre la france et le maghreb
mais entre l'algérie le maroc et la
france
à quoi faut-il être attentif nathan
qu'est ce qui risque de se passer est et
comment voyez vous l'avenir eric denécé
d'écouter les relations entre notre la
france et nos deux partenaires c'est un
petit peu comme un câble de fibre
optique si vous voulez vous avez un
tuyau principal il ya des centaines de
petits fils à l'intérieur chacun de ses
films va correspondre soit de la
coopération antiterroriste soit
économique ce soit une question de visa
soit sur les voilà donc nous avons
énormément de relation avec c'est avec
ces deux pays et je crois que il faut
faire la différence entre ce qui
apparaît dans les médias
déclarations parfois fondées parfois
intempestives des dirigeants politiques
et puis ce qui se trame derrière le
rideau entre services entre diplomates
et que de toute façon nous avons aussi
un parfait que nous soyons dans dans des
trois cas nous avons un intérêt
absolument majeurs a coopéré avec quand
même à une forme de bémol que j'étais
que que j'évoque parce qu'il est il est
essentiel ce ne sont pas les ce n'est
pas la jeunesse française qui cherche à
immigrer au maroc ou en algérie et donc
qu'il ya un véritable problème de
développement et de réponse aux
aspirations des jeunesse marocaine et
surtout algérienne qui doit être résolu
bien sûr parler parler du pays mais à
laquelle peut être la france peut
apporter sa pierre au china shanxi
d'entre le maroc et la france je crois
qu'on n'a pas le choix pour différentes
raisons que de bien s'entendre même si
je ne suis pas tout à fait optimiste
pour l'avenir oui après tout dépend de
la réaction des uns des autres parce
qu'il ya un bras de fer souterrain qui
est en train de s'opérer entre le maroc
et la france puisque le désenclavement
diplomatique dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure au maroc s'est traduit également
par un relatifs déracinement du capital
français au maroc puisque la france a
perdu coup après coup un certain nombre
de marchés au maroc au profit
d'entreprises marocaines dans une
logique de re souveraine isation de
l'économie marocaine alors ça ne va pas
fait pas illogique et ira jusqu'au bout
mais dans une logique de rééquilibrage
la france pourra réagir peut être
négativement par rapport à d'autres
marchés il ya actuellement le tgv de
l'extension du tgv qui en train dé
négocier avec les chinois côté marocain
alors que la première partie a été
opérée par les français donc il y aura
un bras de fer qui va s'installer et
tout dépend de la sagesse des vins et
des autres quant à la nécessité de
trouver un juste milieu par rapport à
l'algérie là pour le coup je suis
vraiment pessimiste parce que je pars de
l'idée que si jamais le régime algérien
se retrouve confronté un schéma
d'implosion imminente du régime je pense
qu'il n'hésitera pas à enrôler la
population algérienne dans une guerre
ouverte et directe contre le maroc comme
étant unique moyen d'échapper à une
implosion du régime une guerre qui sera
de nature effectivement a provoqué une
régression économique de part et d'autre
à déstabiliser toute la région et
peut-être même à ouvrir un boulevard à
une ingérence étrangère dans la région
mais dans tous les cas peut-être je sais
ses objectifs mais je les assume
pleinement
mais je pense que l'unique moyen
effectivement de réenclencher une
nouvelle dynamique au maghreb une
dynamique d'intégration et de
complémentarité de serait soi que le
régime algérien là finissent par revenir
à la raison et entamé une mue vers un
pouvoir politique civile correspondant
désir profond de la plupart des
algériens ou bien un changement de
régime en algérie qui pourrait débloquer
la situation mis à part ces deux
scénarios je ne vois pas comment le
maroc pourrait retrouver une dynamique
l'at-il déjà jamais eu en réalité sinon
sur le papier dans des rapports et dans
des projets adlène meddi
petite parenthèse en réponse à ce qu'a
dit eric denécé sur les les jeunes
maghrébins qui vient en france certes
mais il faut pas oublier même si ça peut
paraître dérisoire en comparaison qui
lie entre 50000 80 mille ressortissants
français au maroc et que dernièrement
les autorités marocaines ont aussi durci
a le le système de délivrance des titres
de séjour aux marocains d'ailleurs et
aux êtres france et d'ailleurs et aux
étrangers en général même si ça reste
symbolique quand on est français au
maroc on doit quitter le territoire au
bout de trois mois et revenir quand on
est clandestin en france est beaucoup
plus compliqué sur les relations
algéro marocain je suis évidemment
beaucoup moins pessimistes que mon
camarade puisque je ne crois pas du tout
à la possibilité d'un conflit armé à
moyen terme ça serait ça serait aberrant
malgré les diversions des du pouvoir
algérien sur les relations
franco-algériennes jeu ce qui m'étonne
c'est que l'intimité franco algérienne
ne conduis hélas pas à une véritable
connaissance ou à une véritable
de comment dire une véritable
circulation de l'information puisque
l'algérie est un pays finalement très
méconnue malgré cette intimité et ça
c'est assez gênant et c'est une question
qui doit se poser je pense à distance de
l'état par des chercheurs par les
intellectuels par les populations elles
mêmes de même je pense que la question
mémorielle doit être géré le plus loin
possible de l'état le bullpen le plus
loin possible des états des deux états
je vous remercie tous les trois devant
participer à ce débat merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro mal prochain numéro
c'est demain et c'est là sa 100ème
d'interdît d'interdire
[Musique]